and welcome back to Hannity so today NFL
Commissioner Roger Goodell sent that
letter to the NFL owners saying that
believe believes everyone should stand
for the national anthem Wow finally
getting on board is what President Trump
has been calling for here with reaction
ourthe over brand-new I don't think this
is gonna outdo your last one you're out
your last book was you know 30 weeks of
the New York Times list newt gingrich
his brand new book is vengeance a former
Speaker of the House and also by the way
his wife Callisto is gonna be the
ambassador to the Vatican she has a new
book out which is the latest installment
of the Ellis the elephant series
remember the ladies she can't sell our
book
she's ELISA you know works for the
American people she can yeah come out
with more congratulations huge win for
Trump I think and he was right to bring
this debate on the NFL and the anthem
absolutely and one of the things that is
driving the elite media crazy is the
Trump has this instinct for taking the
side of the American people and taking
the side of American history and being
willing to stand up to every politically
correct nutcake left-wing are there is
and he's gradually beginning to break
through I think and it gives him a well
of support that's not measurable in
traditional terms I mean all these lead
if you go back and collected all the
elitists who wrote columns about how
wrong it was for Trump to do this well
the average American looked up and said
no that's exactly right and when Dave
Winston and his team did did their poll
and found out that the NFL had collapsed
yes in favor matically I am sure at that
point Roger Goodell suddenly in a moment
of deep patriotism and desire not to go
broke now you're sounding cynical as I
am in life which is I'm refresh refresh
I just think it's funny that you mean
when the ratings went to the lowest
level and Monday Night Football history
in their revenues are sinking it caught
their attention they suddenly decided
that they too wanted to stand for the
flag they too wanted think what you
saying and actually very clever I want
to go back to this Harvey Weinstein
issue because there's a huge political
component here
you've known me all these years I first
interviewed you in 1990 first time it
was in a Holiday Inn in Decatur Alabama
the thing that frustrates me the most is
a lie that is told that Republicans are
racist sexist misogynistic homophobic
xenophobic Islamophobic every two to
four years every election cycle poor
Mitt Romney had resumes of women and was
accused of misogyny it couldn't meet a
nicer guy in your life write it now all
the hypocrisy Hillary takes money from
countries that practice Sharia they take
money from Weinstein everybody I know in
Hollywood says this was an open secret
how abusive and horrible this man was
the casting couch is not a new concept
it didn't matter that Bill Clinton
treated women horribly they still voted
for Bill and Hillary I'm tight why the
double standard well let me say first of
all the bed dominant agenda transom
which is a great daily blog pointed out
two things one if he'll read one this
would still not be a story because they
would have smothered it because it's so
directly brings back up Bill and Hillary
and so in that sense this is a story
that could only emerge when you had
somebody new in the White House to in
the old days people like Weinstein and
this will make an amazing movie an
amazing novel people likewise not just
it's not just him there were people who
had the power that they could go to the
various news publications and then the
various women's publications and say I
can get a star to be the cover of your
next magazine and you really want to
pick a fight with me they owned them and
what has happened is as Dominic's points
out is with the democratization of media
there are too many small people out
there to bribe and so all of a sudden
somebody comes along and says Twitter
I'm willing to do I'm willing to report
this and you can't do anything to me I
think what's interesting is this is
gonna this is and this is part of an
ongoing process you're going to see
Hollywood
now I think come apart at the seams just
as you seen Silicon Valley
come apart at the seams because all of a
sudden it becomes inappropriate for
economic power to call to coerce and
blackmail and bribe people that it has
been exploiting there's a there's an
ugly hypocritical underbelly here though
the left will tolerate the sins of the
left Hollywood celebrities tolerated the
sins of the Clintons because of what
their politics were any conservative the
even if it's not true they'll go forward
with the fierce feigned outrage look I
think what gets to people like you and
me and most of our of our audience is
the left is determined to say that they
are morally superior and that's what
makes their you know the they have to
come in and say whatever the topic is
you're a bad person not just you
disagree in your conservative you're a
bad person and as you said they then
come up with all these nasty big terms
and I just saw a study that the next
generation of college professors people
under 35 today are 12 to one Democrat 12
to one that says to me the campuses are
gone and these are all people who walk
around smugly saying I'm morally
superior and you must be inferior
because after all you don't believe what
I believe do you think they really deep
down in their hearts know how
hypocritical they are no that's what
your evening I think these people are
totalitarian these are the people that
Orwell wrote in 1984 but these are
people who believe sincerely in their
right to crush you and sincerely they
can but they'll tolerate the sins of
their own they'll tolerate a double cap
rose a big green guy he it's not enough
to celebrate New Year's Eve once with a
private jet to Australia and then a
private jet to fly back to Vegas so you
get to celebrate it twice and then of
course you can buy carbon offsets which
is the equivalent of buying you know a
diamond watch ring and necklace if
you're unfaithful to your wife and say
it's just an off set honey no
that'll work what's a carbon offset is
oh I can send all I want I can put out
all the emissions I want but you got to
get rid of your Caravan and drive a
bicycle now you're not gonna jump from
there and a mean-spirited way and start
talking about Al Gore's swing pool I got
a video of Al Gore getting off a Gulf
Stream and it's only him and his wife
which seats 18 you know I can't I'm the
only person in life that can throw you
off I'm sorry
let me totally stop him I have no idea
what I was about to say all right
there's a double standard democracy no I
think I think what drives us crazy is
and candidly one of the things that
saved Bill Clinton was that he was he
knew he was a hypocrite and he was kind
of cheerful about it
it was the people around him who weren't
and if you watch him I mean this guy who
remembered went down and talked to a
group in Houston and said I bet you
raised your taxes too much what heck I
think I did too
you know he just he had this at this
this this Kunduz Arkansas country boy aw
shucks Here I am doing the best I can
that's not what these people are these
people these people are people who would
destroy you you be not just you Sean
Hannity but they're very conservative
well anybody on a college campus who
speaks inappropriately look at Berkley